how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
a clue for avengers endgame has been
discovered in Avengers infinity war
more specifically the post-credits scene
in Avengers infinity war so as we all
know in the post-credits scene of
Avengers infinity war Nick Fury and
Maria Hill are driving in a car when all
of a sudden car start crashing
helicopter start crashing and chaos
breaks out because people are getting
dusted and then sadly we watched Nick
Fury and Maria hill get dusted Maria
hill went first and then Nick Fury ran
to the SUV grabbed the cosmic pager to
call Captain Marvel but while he was
doing so he himself got dusted and we
found out that he was paging Captain
Marvel but you actually hear the clue
before all of the chaos starts so right
before the car crashes in front of hill
and Fury's car you can hear Fury say
tell Klein we'll meet him at and then
BOOM car crash at first you really
wouldn't think anything about what
they're saying your mind automatically
focuses on the chaos and fury and he'll
turn into dust and fury calling Captain
Marvel but a user on reddit has pointed
out who exactly Klein is Klein who Fury
and Hill were supposed to meet up with
is actually Cameron Klein you may not
recognize his name but you might
recognize his face and that's because he
was a very trustworthy agent of shield
and we've seen him in Captain America
the Winter Soldier
Avengers age of Ultron and the Captain
Marvel prelude in Captain America the
Winter Soldier he was a launch tech
SHIELD agent who believed and stayed
loyal to Captain America he refused to
do what Brock rumlow a Hydra agent and
would later be known as crossbones told
him to do and in doing so his courage
caused other shield agents to take
Captain America side then at the end of
age of Ultron when Nick Fury shows up to
save the day with the helicarrier's he
has Klein right there with him number
six boat is topped and locked door or
stock top
it's full of people so why is Klein so
important that Nick Fury and Maria Hill
were going to meet with him during the
middle of an attack on earth
well since shield disbanded he has
remained loyal to Captain America and
has been one of the persons that Nick
Fury and Maria hill trust the most
that's why they recruited him in age of
Ultron to help save the day but recently
we've gotten the Captain Marvel prelude
comic which places an emphasis on his
character they show his character a few
times in the comics but then a very
important emphasis is placed on his
character during the events of civil war
Nick Fury and Maria Hill were monitoring
the Avengers the whole entire time Nick
Fury realizing that a greater threat is
coming decides to go off the grid to do
some missions as he's leaving he asked
agent Hill his client still running
Transpo she says he is he says good
we're gonna need to keep someone we
trust covering our tracks who knows how
long this is gonna take so he is someone
that they extremely trust and still work
with and communicate with often so why
were they're going to meet with Kline
well it seems like that ties in to the
rest of the post-credits scene right
after fury mentions Kline he then
mentions Captain Marvel fury and he'll
are talking about the Avengers an agent
Hill says I've heard to never meet your
heroes they'll only ever let you down
fury says not all of them in which Maria
hill says you got one we haven't called
yet might be helpful to have a back-up
plan in case the worst should ever come
but then fury says nah if we do our job
right we'll never be in a position of
having to call her so now that we know
this let's jump back to the post-credit
scene of Avengers infinity war Earth had
just been visited by aliens
evany ma and Cole obsidian and Tony
Stark went on the alien ship and is now
missing the post-credits scene starts
off with Nick Fury asking Maria he'll
still no word from Stark in which she
replies no not yet we're watching every
satellite on both hemispheres but still
nothing and then she gets an alert that
there are multiple bogies over Wakanda
but they are ten times bigger than the
ones that were in New York but notice
the long pause from fury after Maria
hill says this he's clearly thinking of
a plan and it seems like that plan is
Captain Marvel right now the earth is
being attacked and the Avengers are
still broken up after the events of
Civil War and Tony Stark is nowhere
to be found so it seems like fury thinks
it's time to call in Captain Marvel he
obviously does it in the post-credits
scene but after people start getting
dusted but he was probably going to call
her anyways just probably not right that
second but since he'll got dusted and he
thought he might as well he needed to
call her ASAP but if the decimation did
not happen it seems like he was going to
meet up with Kline and then call Captain
Marvel of course he never met up with
him because him and Maria Hill got
dusted but he did call Captain Marvel
and this is where Kline could play a
huge part in Avengers endgame no one is
going to know who Captain Marvel is none
of the Avengers it's not very likely but
since Klein was so close to fury in
he'll he's going to be the only person
that knows even a little bit about her
and when she gets to earth she's not
gonna know anybody either but she will
know shield so it seems like Klein and
Captain Marvel are going to meet up
somehow and Klein is going to be the one
to find Captain America and introduce
him to Captain Marvel
so Klein could play a really big role in
uniting the Avengers with Captain Marvel
now this is assuming he didn't get
dusted but again they put a lot of
emphasis on him in the Captain Marvel
prelude comic and they did mention his
name in the post-credits scene so it
does seem like they're setting his
character up for a big role but let me
know what you all think about this let
me know what role you think Cameron
Kline will play in Avengers endgame and
I just want to take a moment to say
thank you so much we hit 200,000
subscribers today it's a dream come true
I can't express how much this means to
me how much your support means to me it
means way more than you'll ever know and
I hope to always continue to make videos
that you love so again thank you so much
I'm still doing the giveaway for the
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero and liked
the video as always thank you all so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]